I got from a friend they got this hand
sanitizer it's a lavender hand sanitizer
with a very high alcohol content and
when I spread it all over my hands
i it in deep because it smells like gin
and I used to love Beefeater gin I spent
years in a pool of lukewarm Beefeater
gin Beefeater in and out
martini meaning you put the vermouth in
the glass and by the way if you are a
drinker out there please enjoy this
cocktail and and and I'll tell you
exactly how to do it I don't usually
give cocktail recommendations on the
program because I am a degenerate
alcoholic so many people are disturbed
when I do that but take some vermouth
extra dry vermouth you swirl it around
the glass you throw it out in and out in
and out the martini go right out there
then you put then you take the gin you
stir the [ __ ] gin you don't shake it
like you're a 24 year old [ __ ]
bartender in West Hollywood
who's [ __ ] shaking the gin and trying
to see how many [ __ ] she can fit in her
so she can pay a rent that ain't it okay
you're not gonna you're not shaking a
[ __ ] thing and bruising the goddamn
gin waiting for your [ __ ] seeking
arrangement state to pick you up and
take you to his [ __ ] house enough
you're stirring the gin you stir it
shaking it bruises it it splits in lines
from James Bond it's absolutely true and
let me tell you right now I threw my
life away for this trick I mean I threw
my life away for this drink this studio
is in an apartment in Hollywood I am
more talented than 90% of people that
live in this city and they all live in
castles so the reality is I am [ __ ]
and it was because of this cocktail I
have not had a meaningful relationship
in my life because of this cocktail I
have very few friends and the ones I
have that I've had for a very long time
I strongly dislike I I have no honesty
with myself or others I am a a a shell
of a human being genuine shell of a
human being I live to entertain people
to make them happy for nothing for no
reason I barely enjoy that
what I have to do I'm built to do
nothing else I'm just a vector of
negative energy that will either go into
a heroin needle or go into a stupid joke
I tell it [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
you know the giggle [ __ ] the giggle
Pig which should be the name of a comedy
club in is it
welcome to the giggle Pig don't take out
your phones this is art but what I'm
saying is all of that happen I should
have been I should have came out of the
closet earlier I should have did the
right thing I shouldn't went to college
I didn't do any of that
I was his subprime mortgages I was dumb
enough to sell the product to myself I
sold the house to myself you're not
supposed to get so drunk you scammed
yourself i scammed myself the Enron
idiots weren't buying their own bed [ __ ]
like you know so I did it all for this
perfect drink it is a perfect trick and
I'm glad I was an alcoholic when I look
back on the world I'm glad I would say
you know family friends accomplishments
I know a lot of people with those and I
got to be honest with you truly it's
truly or whatever your kids are [ __ ]
half the time they take advantage of you
they don't value the sacrifices you made
for them your wife or husband doesn't
really care and and and your career it
you hit a wall with that and no one
really gives a [ __ ] truly no one cares I
just watched a documentary about a bunch
of comedians that came out of New York
City in the alt scene and everything and
some of them are funny and some of them
aren't but the point is truly no one
can't no one cares no one cares he care
about david dobrik and they're not gonna
care about him soon they won't care
about him soon they'll care about
something that just makes sounds and
Biebs it'll go give the better educator
your kids like the most will be somebody
that goes so it's over and nothing
matters so you take to vermouth and you
swirl it around in the glass you spill
it out and then you put the gin which
should be and this is another great line
which isn't mine I don't know who wrote
this vodka goes down too easy gin
drinkers like to know what you're up
against that's why I didn't like Bombay
sapphires too smooth I like Beefeater I
like a little punch I
a little punch in the back of the throat
of juniper berry and botanical and
lavender I like to feel where I'm going
cuz this listen martinis gin martinis
take you to the moon martinis are like
breasts
one is not enough two is alright three
is too many
four is a party I didn't do that either
that's something else I don't know a guy
told me that name Huey he's dead the
point is this he had a lot of great
he said one other thing that I left so
hard it wasn't his but he remembered it
he goes she brought he said this at
dinner he goes she broke my heart so I
broke her jaw again I don't know where
you got it it's probably the famous
thing it's very funny anyway he was I
saying you're just describing yeah so
the drink takes you to the moon it takes
you to the moon you get [ __ ] up when
you get banged up on martinis you get
bang the [ __ ] up you do not I mean it's
a bad it's a boom like you are it's no
word like you're at work the next day
with a pounding headache it's a real
hangover you got to do a couple of
percocet in the morning or a couple of
vicodin with that with that [ __ ]
Starbucks latte and that Newport or
marlboro menthol light or Marlboro light
or Marlboro red or Parliament you get
the idea or vape the point is and I've
smoked all those cigarettes that's why I
went through them the point is I used to
smoke basic unfiltered yeah back when I
was a kid I was 13 years old you're my
friend Shea got a pack a basic
unfiltered we got a pack one day have
Benson & Hedges we used to just buy
different types of cigarettes L&M
Liggett & Myers what a good documentary
about cigarettes not about how [ __ ] up
they are about the tradition of tobacco
which did probably have to do that's
probably that's gets into slaves but not
that I mean a recent like what were all
the cigarette companies and I'm
interested in I want to know about that
I'm gonna die one day because of them I
want to know more about them not just a
rat documentary like rat Leah Remini who
everybody hates
Scientology now that they're
millionaires but they didn't they didn't
hate it they didn't mind torturing the
kids when it was getting them all the
opportunities I see you rats you're all
full of [ __ ] okay you don't do something
for 30 [ __ ] years and then decide
it's not for you shut the [ __ ] up go out
like the [ __ ] mafia and suck David
Miscavige's dick all right anyway the
drink this is my point here I keep
getting back I keep it away from this
but the drink but the vermouth then put
to gin no olives olives are for women my
boss told me that my boss who's uh guy
named Tim that I worked for him
mortgages had a scar across his face he
said I said how did you get that because
I was thrown out of a car at four years
old through the windshield I said that's
crazy he goes yeah he goes it taught me
about responsibility no one knew what
that meant
no one asked him but he said olives are
for women it's a great point if you of a
blue cheese stuff olive in your mouth
you're a woman that's it or you're gay I
guess we could say that but even gay
guys predominantly are probably on an
out I don't know that the martini people
martinis are for you know martinis are
for people that want to go to the moon
they don't have to want to go to the
moon with a drink or two they don't have
time to sit there for though they need
to be [ __ ] up by the appetizer I
needed to be in the bag by the appetizer
if bruschetta or tuna tartare hit the
table and I wasn't in a bag we had a
problem I needed to have that gin glow
on my face that heat that heat on my
face before the appetizer hit the table
so it's very important that you make to
drink the right way just just lukewarm
chin in a martini glass you can even I
didn't have a mood sometimes I just do
it with the gin it's nice if you have a
martini shaker you could do it in a milk
glass you know big bar glass water glass
you can do that little stir you know
it's it's here's the thing folks and a
lot of people won't tell you this it's
it is classy to throw your life away
drinking certain drinks
Martini's kettle on the rocks whiskey
bourbon scotch
they're nice something nice about
throwing your life away
like that not beer that's low-rent but
like a liquor alcoholic i always said
good for him that's somebody that knows
where they're going and desperately
wants to get there as quickly as
possible when you were boozing it up you
drank beer right Light beer that's like
be I mean you can even be proud of that
but you didn't even have a good with it
what did you drink from college to what
you were told to what like 19 to like 25
yeah yeah I would say that was me too I
think I was like 19 and 25 because I was
drugs from 13 to 20 and of course from
20 to 25 as well but I I got into booze
when I was done with all the other drugs
when I quit everything else I moved into
booze I graduated to booze the good old
kettle one on the rocks with a black fly
in the glass from the good old
bartenders at Lisa's lounge but that's
that's what I mean you know I threw my
entire life away for that drink and I
don't regret it either I don't it was a
great there's nothing better than a
Sunday afternoon getting shit-faced yeah
and going to sleep in your car yeah you
know you know getting really sure there
was a place called Churchill's and
Rockville Center and I was asked to
leave twice because I think one of the
women in Churchill's one of the women I
was I was drunk and it was 11 a.m. and I
was telling my table of people how
important it was that we continue to
support the people of Iraq by sending
more troops and money and I was
screaming and top my lungs and yelling
and a woman started screaming at me from
across that you don't know what you're
talking about I and I was screaming and
I was drunk I think I called her a
terrorist and I was asked to leave
I was really rare and a go I believed in
the Bush administration and then I and
then I stopped doing cocaine and
drinking and then I
Wow oh it's amazing what happens when
you start looking at things through the
lens of somebody that's you know not
doing cocaine and drinking daily you do
get a better idea of what's going on in
the world I mean I used to go nuts like
I used to get coked out of my face put a
bunch of friends in my suburban drive
around and really wealthy areas in Long
Island and point to the houses and go
they deserve this money they deserve it
yeah better than we are screaming
sweating screaming and my friends are
like yeah yeah back of the car they were
terrified they're like are we gonna die
what's wrong with this guy I mean they
deserve it don't take their money make
your own money and then sometimes the
car would run out of gas like in the
middle of those cuz I hadn't put gas in
it I would just stand outside of the car
screaming just smoking cigarettes and
screaming like when I said I completely
destroyed my life I mean you know it's
I'm sure you know there's elements of it
that are fun but you know I should have
just vlogged that's what I should have
done I should have logged